I'm Alyssa Chen and I'm al Jazeera's
correspondent in San Francisco I way way
is one of the world's most well-known
contemporary artists you might have seen
something he's done even if you didn't
realize it if you watch the beijing
olympics in 2008 that national stadium
the bird's nest was co-designed by AI
weiwei that was before he became
politically active and unpopular with
the Chinese government what's really
interesting about this exhibit is that I
weiwei himself was imprisoned for 81 day
so he knows exactly what it feels like
to be in a jail cell and there's
something really interesting with the
fact that he can't leave China right now
so he has had to build this project
completely in abstention movado Chico
DeBarge adduced at me door I'm Jarrett
Ravi Booya
there are these pictures of political
prisoners 176 of them made up of Legos I
weiwei has essentially become a global
political activist by representing so
many countries showing 30 countries
where there are political prisoners
being held and that's really symbolic I
think you'll notice the name of this
exhibit at large with the @ symbol is
something very close to AI weiwei's
heart he once told me in an interview
that Twitter is more important to him
than art and it's precisely with this
modern technology that I has been able
to set up these seven installations on
Alcatraz Island want more download the
aj+ mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now